hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the mr dodgy invitational the
prestigious one uh that is 2.0 it's
anishgi reverses
obama and the juba already defeated
alexander grisha can wit it
and now he needs to take down another
one of the candidates uh that is anish
giri
and there were a lot of games to choose
from i decided to show you this one
uh even though the entire game might not
be as
exciting as you might hope the the part
of the game that i'm going to show you
uh
will be and i'm going to show you the
entire game but we're just going to
focus on the
uh really important uh part so gary has
the white pieces and he opens with
e4 uh sorry about that
he opens with e4 we have c5 going for
the sicilian defense knight to f3 and
now
e6 we have d4 uh captures captures and
knight
to f6 now we have knight to c3 and
bishop to b4
inviting white to go for a very very uh
sharp line that is
e5 and here anish goes for it uh we have
knight to d5 now with a double attack on
the c3 knight
and even though queen to g4 is a really
interesting move here
now for example you could go some like
queen g4 then allow a capture here
uh it's not good or anything but
sometimes black might capture here but
then you're just going to play queen
captures on g7
and there really is no good discovery
once you go back deliver check with the
bishop we're just going to play c3
attack the bishop
and now you have to play something the
rook is still hanging so for example
rook f8 captures here
and white will be white will be much
better here
so instead after knight to d5 we have
this bishop to d2 move and this is the
strongest move uh
objectively with bishop captures b
captures now doubling the c
pawn for the moment but you will use the
extra c pawn to kick away the knight
from this
uh excellent d5 outpost so here we have
castles
and c4 now attacking the knight knight
to e7
and now uh there are some games where
bishop to d3 was played also bishop to
b4 is a known move but here we have
knight to b5
and it is as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so let's see
how uh balur continues here
uh he plays knight to c6 there is really
no way
of stopping knight coming to d6 so he's
not even trying
uh bishop to c3 defending the e5 pawn
and now
a6 uh chasing away the knight so knight
does come to d6
but now uh uh badou plays knight
captures on e5 point is that if the
bishop is captured then the queen can
connect with
check and pick up this bishop for
example bishop captures queen to a5 with
check now we have to block this for
example c3 and now
captures with check so what you play
here you have to play something
also you're going to lose the c3 pawn
with check then king to f1 and then
it's just black who's better so instead
what anisha
figured here he said okay we're gonna
leave the knight where it is
we just start expanding with h4 now he
wants to get
h5 and h6 in we have f6 now defending
this knight on e5 and here
and he just continues pushing his h pawn
so h5
we have knight to f7 now offering a
trade here but also keeping an eye on
the h6 square
but aneesh doesn't care he just
sacrifices a second pawn so here
h6 so here you can see that white really
doesn't care about pawns already
sacrificing the second pawn doubling his
c
pawn uh so what uh what is the point of
all this well the knight is on a
beautiful square here uh
pretty much paralyzing black's entire
development the bishop is on an
excellent square and now
after sacrificing this h pawn as you'll
see knight captures
bishop is coming to d3 and we basically
reach the position from the thumbnail
where the bishop
pair is fully operational so let's see
what
what can anish do with this fully
operational bishop
pair we have knight the g6 adding
another
defender here and now comes c5 here
locking this knight uh on v6 so it
doesn't uh
uh it's not all that easy for black to
attack it and here a black
should play f5 with f5 you're really uh
limiting the power of this light square
bishop
however queen to c7 was played here and
now anish
goes in for the kill he plays rook
captures on h6
uh makes sense i mean we all knew that
this was happening next year
probably gonna move the queen later on
maybe you can even bring this rook into
the attack
so g captures and now queen to h5
this is the only winning move for white
and of course anish goes for it
we have b6 preparing to pick up the c5
pawn and then offer a queen trade and
here we have
bishop cactus and g6 again the correct
way to continue
and now black really doesn't have a
good reply here for example if the if
the bishop is captured we're just going
to play queen captures and you're
getting checkmated for example king here
we're going to capture here and after
the king moves back king g6
king here and then we're just going to
play castle's queen side and
there is no defense against the rook to
h1 so instead after bishop captures on
c6 bador played queen captures on c5
he offered a queen trade but it doesn't
matter because the position is still
completely winning for white
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for anish
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
playing the only move that wins well
sort of only uh capturing the queen also
wins but we don't want to play that and
that is
bishop to f7 check so congratulations to
everyone who found it uh point is uh
that
there is really is no good move here if
the kings were just going to capture
with the bishop
this is checkmate so your best hope is
to just play king the g7
but now comes the real problem and that
is bishop captures on f6
and now you really don't have a move
only move is to capture with the king
and now
knight the e for check forks the king
and the queen and that's it
there's uh no real point in playing this
knight captures b
captures and now we uh okay the bishop
uh
will be lost but it doesn't matter we
can just play the
captures here d captures queen captures
we're gonna get the rook into the game
we have a queen and the rook against two
rooks and the bishop this is
this is completely winning but as i
mentioned these are blitz games five
minutes per player no seconds increment
so of course players will miss things so
after queen captures on c5
uh anish played queen captures an h6
thinking okay it's even better because
we're just gonna to check medium we
don't
care about this queen captures on c3 but
as it turns out there's a problem of
course uh jabal will not capture on g6
he's going to capture this with uh
check we have king to e2 and now
of course not captures rook but rather
queen to e5 with
check we have knight the e4 blocking
check
and now rook to f7 this is how uh joba
defends against checkmate
and now white will really have to
struggle to prove that he's better he
plays bishop captures on f7
uh you might consider bringing the rook
to h1 first but okay
bishop captures an f7 king captures and
queen captures an h7
king to e8 now queen h8 check king to e7
queen g7 check
came to d8 and now queen captures on f6
with
check and now uh we enter an end game
where the material is completely equal
captures captures
and now you can see that it's bishop and
rook against the bishop and
knight against the rook and knight with
four pawns each
and even black black has two pawn
islands whereas white has three pawn
island so if anything black is better
here
uh it's a game on both sides of the
board and black has the bishop so
uh gary missed his chance of of uh just
uh
you know uh uh winning this game very
very early on and here this is only move
uh 29 in the game last at some 80 moves
and
well both of them are very good players
and this game
did end in a draw so i'm going to show
it to you what happened king the e7
and we're just gonna quickly uh go
through it because uh
well nothing really really interesting
happened in this end game but we will
show it as you know
it is uh what we do here but i really
wanted to show you
the this game because of the first part
of the game so not not much really
happening here
uh later on uh we did have some uh some
interesting moves for example here uh
upon was sacrificed so
uh anish could start pushing his past g
pawn for example king d4
98 and now uh you could capture the pawn
uh for example if bishop captures knight
captures and b6 and now for example
e5 but it doesn't really matter because
whatever you play let's say b3 you push
the pawn
c3 check we're just going to eliminate
this pawn captures captures
and now it doesn't matter that black is
up a piece because after let's say c4
king d4 we can just play king b2
give up the pawn and it's uh the bishop
is of the wrong color we're on a dark
square he has a light square bishop so
of course you cannot win this
uh so instead of this uh king the e5 was
played
then g5 white started pushing his pass
pawn but now bishop
e4 c4 with bishop to g6 attacking the
knight
knight c7 and now a5 so uh not much for
either sides to do here
king to b3 was played with bishop to f5
and
now king to a4 and going after this pawn
we have king to d4
and now g6 giving up the pawn for this
pawn
we have captures captures with check and
now king captures and c4 king captures
on a5
and now there is no way of winning this
a few more moves were played and
white uh tried black tried something but
of course white
did not allow it here uh if you capture
of course the pawn falls this is just
draw by insufficient material so a few
more moves were played and not uh
and not uh not a lot to say about this
uh but in the end the game ended in a
draw but i really wanted to show it to
you there were
a couple of games to choose from i still
decided to show you this one even though
it ended in a draw
because this wonderful wonderful up
until this point it was just uh you know
uh total annihilation and had geary
uh uh uh played after queen captures on
c5
something like what was discussed here
bishop to f7 check or queen captures on
c5 even
uh this game would have ended very very
quickly uh but yeah
that's the game uh in the end uh anish
defeated uh jobaba
by uh the score of seven to three which
is really really impressive and it all i
i guess it all kind of started
they went back and forth with their wins
but then uh badur dropped a rook
he he suffered a loss due to a mouse
slip and then i guess it kind of you
know
it's it's too much to against the player
like anish when something like this
happens to
uh then it all just you know starts
piling up maybe you have to use
a bit sharper lines not the ones that
you were hoping to use maybe
to keep it more safe who knows but yeah
another match that was tarnished by by
the mouse slip
so yeah congratulations to anish for
winning yet again
mr dodgy invitational uh they said that
if they invited him again that he would
have to play with handicap
because he's obviously too strong here
uh so we'll see we'll see how it goes
and
will will there be a mr dodge
invitational 3.0 i guess the
it will yeah because uh it's uh you know
people do enjoy it a lot
uh so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it or at least
the part uh that led to this position
uh i would like to thank david joffrey
cook it's unconsolable kevin hawkins and
austin del rio for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day